皆さんこんにちは枚入ってます大丈夫ですか
facebook の代表やってます長谷川です今日ですね
あの地元でもある関西でこのようにたくさんの若い方とお話するのをすごく楽しみにし
てきました
私の方からですね10個のチェンジについてお話したいと思います
夏は私自身の人生キャリアで起こったチェンジ
あるいは天気そして残りの3つはですね
今グローバルで起こっているチェンジの中でもフェイスブックが特に注目している
トレンドについてお話したいと思います
まずは私自身のチェンジについてなんですけどチェンジについてお話しする前に
スターティングポイントについてお話したいと思います
後ろの方ですねちょっと遠いので買うまで見えてないかもしれませんが結構私顔が
コインでハーフですかとかってよく言われます
まあ祝い等のフィリピンとか針とか赤道経営の方ですね
まあただ私が知ってる限りはですね両親共に日本人で
で一応それの証拠写真がこちらですね
左が父良一そして右が母トミコ
この2人の間でですね何かスパークが起こって1977年にこのように生まれてまいり
ました
あの日本人なんですけど2歳から実はアメリカのシアトルで育ってます
この写真の通りですね現地のローカルのよう
土屋ローカルの小学校に行きましたので友達もみんなアメリカ人
初恋もおぼろげなんですけどおそらく金髪のですね
アメリカ人 no 7個ということで非常にアメリカンな幼少期を過ごしました
そんな私に大きな転機が訪れたのが9歳の時ですね
父親の仕事の関係で今度は日本に帰国をしてそして兵庫県の公立の小学校にた酔うこと
になりました
まだ日が浅いときですね一つのまあシーンをすごく今でも鮮明に覚えていますそれが
こちらですね
組体操の練習です
皆が同じ服を着て人が人の上に積み重なってピラミッドを形成するというコンセプトは
残念ながらアメリアメリカには存在しないんですね
すげーなということで非常に大きなカルチャーショックを受けたのを覚えています
加えて私自身もあんまり日本が上手じゃなかったのでわかんない単語英語になっちゃう
んですね
日本語と英語がこう混ざっちゃう例えば僕のペン層が僕のイメージするが得
teacher みたいな感じでですねまぁのいうなれば
ルー大柴のような生徒が急にですね公立の小学校のクラスに入ってきたということ
で周りの子供もおそらく先生もものすごい暑扱いづらかったんじゃないかなというふう
に思っています
まあそんな中でなんとか生き延びまして
1996年ここ京都の京都大学に入学しました
私はですね大会のハンドボール部に入部したんですけれどもその3回生の時に一つ非常
に大きな転機がありました
それがですねハンドボール部のキャプテンに就任したことです
もともとは勝ちたいという熱い思いがあればいいキャプテンになれる
それでチームも勝てるそう僕は思ってました実際やってみるとそういう誰よりも熱い
気持ちを持っていてもチームはついて来ず試合にも勝てず
非常に苦しいキャプテンの毎日が続きましたまあそういう中でそのチェーン
ジョー通じて私達はリーダーというのはただ単に高い視座とか
ビジョンを持っているだけではダメでそれをポジティブな形で仲間にチームメンバーに
伝播させる
そういうことができないと結果が出ないインパクトが出せないそういうことを学びまし
た
その後ですね卒業して東京会場という保険会社に週に就職しました
法人営業をやってからその後ですね
外資系のメーカーに就職しましたこれはいわゆる転職ですねマーケティング本部に入っ
てこの写真では結構ですね
いい感じで笑顔なんですけど最初の位置には特にも地獄でした
自分自身が前の会社で身につけたスキルとか
業務能力そういうものが一切通用しない
ものすごく早く焦る気持ちで苦しい1年を過ごしました
ただそういう中でですね運命的な出会いが一つありました
それは就職したこの会社におけるプロジェクトマネジメントの考え方仕組みです
この会社ではですね例えば私最初紙おむつのブランド思ってたんですけど将来か妙物の
新製品を出しますということでプロジェクトチームを組成する時ですねまず最初にやる
ことは
成功を定義することなんですね
このプロジェクトがある場合とない場合で勝者に対して世の中に対してそしてビジネス
に対してどういうインパクトをもたらしたいのか
これをディファインサクセスと言います
そして成功を明確に定義した上でそこに至るためにはどういうタイミングでどうなって
なきゃいけないのか
そういうタスクリスクをちゃんと日にちも入れてやるんです
で確かにこういうようにちゃんとやっていくとプロジェクトの成功確率は上がるなぁと
いうことですごく感銘を受けた覚えがあります
一方で僕自身がその時思った事は新製品を出すというプロジェクトも重要なんだけれど
も僕自身にとって最も重要なプロジェクトは何なのかそれは自分自身の人生であり
そしてキャリアじゃないと
もしプロジェクトの成功確率を上げる方法がコレなんであれば自分の人生を一つの
プロジェクトとしてみてそれでしっかりやってみたらどうかということでですね
15年ほど前に自分の人生のノートというものを作りました
それの1ページ目には先ほどと全く同じようにじゃあ人生の成功を定義する
例えば自分自身が死ぬ日を思い浮かべる孫たちに対してじいちゃんの人生はこんなん
だったというどういうストーリーを語りたいのかそして心の底から移す嘘偽りなくそれ
を孫たちに話した
たいと思ったらどういう経験を踏まなきゃいけないのか
何歳までにどうなってなきゃいけないのかそれが僕の人生のノートの一枚目です
そしてそれがその後の15年間
人生を呼びキャリアにおける大きな方針を決め
そして岐路に立った時のディシジョンメイキングのバックボーンになっています
そういうものに基づいてキャリアを歩んできました
その後ですね10年間外資系のメーカーにはいたんですけどそのうちナッパ7年経った
時点でシンガポールに赴任しました
その中で行ったのは多様性です
この一番上の段がですねその2年間のアサインメントの中で出会ったジョーシン
中段と下段がですね僕と一緒にアジアの仕事をしてくれた仲間たちですね
見ていただける通り本当にいろんな国籍のいろんな人たちと仕事しました
そして同時にそれまで自分自身が日本という国で同じような教育を受け
同じような文化的阻止考え方の背景を持つ人たちといかに阿吽の呼吸とかなんとなく
通じるというものに頼っ
で仕事をしてきたかというところに気づいて愕然としました
そしてこういうところでもマネ歩はれる中で可用性のあるチームと働く
難しさ楽しさそしてその中でしっかりやっていくためのスキルというものを身につけた
と思います
そのような経験はその後ですねインターネットカンパニーに転職をしゼロから今度は
グローバルのマーケティングをしっかりやっていくそういうチームをゼロから作った時
にもいろんな国籍のいろんなスキルを持つ仲間を作るという意味で非常に役に立ちまし
たしそういうものが新しいバリューをどんどん作っていくんだということ
で確信に変わりました
そしてです2年前 facebook の日本の代表に収入をして今はですね
会社のミッションに基づき世界中をつないでそしてコミュニティという形で応援をし
それによって人と人の距離が縮まって少しでも世界が良くなるようにということで日々
仕事をしています
ここまでですね僕の人生そしてキャリアにおけるチェンジ
天気についてお話しました結構チェンジが幸か不幸か多かった人生だと思います
そしてその中で結構色々学びましたので少しお話させていただきます
まず
チェンジは甘くないです
結構ですね世の中にはもうチェンジャー何でもかんでもいいことだと何でもいいから
チェンジ起こせと戦時があれば飛び込めという方もたくさんいらっしゃいます
僕はそうは思わないです
僕自身が人生で経験したチェンジそれは自分自身で選べなかった
例えばアメリカから日本に帰ってくるというようなこともあるいは自分自身で選んだ
外資系メーカーとか it カンパニーに転職をするというチェンジもどれ一つとって
も甘くなかったです
むしろ苦しみの連続でした
なのでチェンジは甘くない
一方で振り返ると自分自身が大きく成長したのはそういうチェンジの中で歯を
食いしばって何とかもがきながら頑張ってたときそれが最も成長した時でありそして
世の中ですね
チェンジのスピードが上がっていてその振れ幅もどんどん大きくなっていくそういう中
で活躍される方おそらくこう
こういう苦しい展示を乗り越えて成長して
そしてその過程自体を楽しめるそういう人がおそらく今後活躍される
僕は確信しています
ここからですね今度は世界で起こっているチェンジの中で僕らフェイスブックが最も
注目している3つについてお話したいと思います
まず1つ目
モバイルシフトです
今世界中で携帯電話に契約をしている人50億人いると言われています
そして回戦ベースだと70億を超えていると言われています
この50億人という数字
は例えばきれいなトイレにアクセスのある人
あるいは歯ブラシを持っている人よりも多いというような指標もあります
こういう数字規模感を見ると数年前から皆さんもおそらく世界はモバイルに向かって
いるみたいな話を聞いたと思うんですけどこれを見るとですねもう
携帯電話モバイルというものが世界のインフラとして浸透しきってもう今や
モバイルの世界になっているというのがグローバルのプラットフォームを運営する僕ら
の実感つです
そしてもうひとつこのモバイルシフトと同じぐらいですね重要なトレンドがあります
それは人と人の繋がり方が進化し多様化しているというトレンドです
どういうことなのか例えば一昔前ですね皆さんイタリアに行ってきれいな景色を見ます
あるいはまあ京都だと嵐山に行って紅葉綺麗なものを見ますそうするとテキストでです
ね嵐山の紅葉綺麗だよと売ってたと思うんですね
それがまだまだガラケーの時ですね
携帯電話にカメラが搭載されてそして写メールのようなそういう共有するようなそう
いう機能が付くとどうなったのか
写真でコミュニケーションするようになります
当然ながら嵐山の紅葉は写真の方がよく伝わるんですね
例えば僕らインスタグラムというプラットフォームを運営しています
いまや世界で月間のアクティブアカウントが8多くを超え日本においてもインスタ倍と
いうような言葉が生まれていますインスタグラムなぜそこまで広がったのか
当然インスタグラム自身も結構いろんな努力はしてきたんですけどそれ以上に
この生活車ユーザーの皆さんが
のコミュニケーションのあり方がテキストからビジュアルに移行した
そういう非常に大きなトレンドに乗っかったと僕らは思っています
この後どうなるのかスマートフォンの浸透です
日本においても5800万人の方がスマートフォンを持っていると言われています
そしてスマートフォンを持つということは一人一人の手のひらの中に
高精度のビデオカメラがあるということです
僕が小さい頃名古屋におじいちゃんがいるんですけど
映写機とビデオカメラを持っているだけで街のヒーローだったんですねそれが今や
全員の手のひらの中にあるするとどうなるか
人と人の繋がり方が動画になります
動画でリッチなコミュニケーションするこれが今のコミュニケーションのど真ん中です
ます
実際フェイスブック上でも毎日毎日80億回以上の動画が再生されています
今日も80億足球80億それぐらいの規模感で動画というものが人々の
コミュニケーションのど真ん中に入っていってます
じゃあこの先どうなるのかおそらく10年スパンで見たとき
br や ar といったようなテクノロジーを使って相手方が嵐山にいなくても
相手方の意思で自分自身で景色を見回せる
そしてそのす景色を共有しながらコミュニケーションをとるそういう世界が10年
スパンではくると我々は信じています
が今はど真ん中は動画です
そして最後のトレンドそれはグローバルで繋がる世界です
これはですね例えばフェイスブックで今月間でです20億人の人が全く同じ
プラットフォームを毎月毎月使ってます
そして自由にその20億人の中でつながりそしてコミュニケーションをとってます
これ例えばビジネスで言うとどういうことなのか昔であればインドやアメリカや
ヨーロッパでビジネスをしようと思うと
向こうまで飛んで行って向こうの商習慣でいろんなネゴシエーションしておそらく現地
にチームを置いてようやく
starting line 食べたそれがおそらくスタンダードだったと思います
今や
この会場でですインターネットが繋がっていて
パソコンが一台あるいはスマートフォンが一台あればですね
20億人のなかから自分自身のサービスが刺さりそうな人に向けて直接
コミュニケーションをしたり
つながったり物を売ったりそういうことができる時代です
これは明らかにですね世界におけるつながり方コミュニケーションの取り方
そしてビジネスにおける非常に大きな
パラダイムシフトです
このように世界でいろんなトレンドが起こっていますその中でも世界がモバイルに
向かって言っている
そして人と人の繋がりのど真ん中が今
ビジュアル動画になっている
そして世界中がつながってボーダーがなくなるそういう世界が来ているというチェンジ
についてお話しました
そしてこのような大きなチェンジが起こっているとき当然ながら大きなチャンスがあり
ます
ですがそういうチェンジをしっかりと捉えて
そしてインパクトを出そうと思ったとき
必ずクレイジーネスだけではなくてどういうトレンドが起こっていて自分自身と
向き合って具体的に何がしたいのかっていうのを冷静に見極める
そういう視点が極めて重要になってきます
そしてもう一つ facebook が例えばこの規模まで来たというのはクレイジー
ネスだけではなくて世界中をつなげて少しでも世界を良くしたい
オープンにしたいそういう信念覚悟をずっと持ち続けて十数年間やってきたからなん
です
なのでチェンジだって言ってあっちこっち行くだけ
クレイジーに何かとりあえず試すだけではダメです本当にインパクトを出したいと思っ
たらトレンドを見極め
自分自身と見極めて冷静に判断をしてそして信念を持ってインパクトを出しに行くそう
いうことが極めて重要だと思っています
最後に
facebook の社員が好んで使う言葉をご紹介したいと思います
それは冒険はまだ1%しか終わってない
これからまだまだ99%残っている
大変だけどそれを楽しみながらワクワクしながらガンガンいこうぜそういう意味です
おそらく世の中にインパクトを与えるという意味では皆さんのほとんどがですね
まだここから99%というそういうフェーズになっていると思います
是非今後のですね冒険をワクワクしながら
ずっとフルスピードで進んでいっていただきたいと思いますご静聴ありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]